well let's start with you I mean on the
face of it it doesn't look like China's
doing very much we can't really know
what's going on behind the scenes but
why do you think that is I think Joan is
always preferred the status quo but as
you can have you seen from all the
announcements from President Trump to
nikki Haley his an ambassador to the UN
the status quo is not good enough for
America and seen the last nuclear
missile that and North Korea has
launched which has five times the impact
I believe of Hiroshima I think this is
obviously something which the Chinese
will be pushed to do something more but
I think the big question with all of
this is what is that something more and
can President Trump really deliver his
threat to cut off all trade with
countries that do business with North
Korea I looked this up in 107 countries
export to North Korea to the US and
China obviously is the biggest one 90%
of North Korean trade and the u.s. is
47th and cutting off trade with a
hundred seven countries I'm sure that's
not what President Trump means but that
would be obviously a massive step if it
came to that to push the Chinese to do
more yeah I mean there's no point in
going ahead with sanctions against North
Korea unless the Chinese are involved
no there absolutely isn't they'll have a
Security Council resolution being
considered on Monday I believe and I
think we'll have to see what in the
wording of that China is a permanent
member of the Security Council and so
they will have to come on a board but
they may want concessions in return
they're very concerned about Trump's
relationship with South Korea with Japan
and so let's not forget that
relationship it's not just a military
relationship transaction muddling the
waters he's threatening to pull out of
the South korea-us Strait you as well
which of course means our security and
trade are now intricately linked yeah I
mean I got this is the point that
Linda's just made I mean Trump he can't
be serious about cutting off business
with countries that do business with
North Korea that's not a credible threat
and I think that's the problem with
Trump tweeting is that he's making
threats that he cannot deliver so there
are several options that the u.s. can go
for through the UN more sanctions and
maybe going for oil like on the last
sanctions in
August 25th they went for iron for coal
but this time they could go for oil but
you still need to have China's support
China is a member as you said it's a
member of the UN and is bound by the
same sanctions
the problem is enforcement you can agree
to the sanctions if you don't enforce
them that's the issue
I mean it's a case you're saying Trump
actually quite likes it he wouldn't mind
a pretext for putting up trade barriers
against China and I thought that was
what he won the u.s. election on it's
true it's true but in that case it would
inflict so much damage on the US economy
that that would be nonsensical to go for
that they could also go for the
financial route and try to target
companies or banks Chinese banks or
Russian banks that are having business
with North Korean companies but even
that route is a little bit sensitive
because they could backfire some of
these Chinese banks are very large and
they have links with US companies as
well what do you think Charlie can be
relied on to uphold any sanctions that
are assuming the UN Security Council
goes for it can you will join or
actually upholding can we trust them to
and I think they would if they agreed
with the sanctions and that's the
biggest I think they have upheld
previous sanctions but in terms of scale
obviously hasn't done enough to deter
North Korea and I think one of the
issues with China and North Korea is
that North Korea does have a slight
habit of provoking other countries
getting something in return they recall
a few years ago they would get some aid
in return if they stopped their nuclear
testing apparently they didn't so I
would actually say for China it's a huge
headache because they have this
unreliable state on its borders that if
major sanctions were levied on North
Korea it could cause an exodus over
Chinese borders or worse conflict breaks
out in the Korean Peninsula and the
biggest land border between North Korea
is with actually with China not even
with South Korea do you get a sense that
Kim is trying to provoke China I mean
this latest test has come just as Xi
Jinping is welcoming people to the
latest BRICS conference in Beijing yeah
I know it's not I before I answer that
I'm not quite sure I know how strategic
the North Koreans are maybe you do
didn't know what they're doing in this
matter they know it that's the thing
like we portray them as crazy as mad but
they're actually very rational they're
pursuing their interest vaio yes in that
case my my my assumption going into it
is that the BRICS summit is obviously
China's way of showing they are the
leader of emerging markets Brazil Russia
India South Africa are there and if
North Korea's be strategic than what
they're probably trying to do is to get
China's attention because I don't think
she Jean King which I said he has a lot
on his mind he's got a leadership
renewal five-year renewal coming up next
month North Korea is not high on his
agenda and he does need I think in many
ways for China to essentially reiterate
the status quo if that Elise stops the
United States somewhat pushes back a bit
otherwise the u.s. is absolutely taking
the lead on what's happening to North
Korea but in the past it's always been
the six-party talks which involve China
Russia South Korea Japan and the u.s.
that's made the most progress on North
Korea as small as it is what did you
make of Linda's point though about
turning off the oil supply I mean that's
going to create a refugee crisis I was
going to rebound on the point of the
u.s. taking leadership I don't think
actually the u.s. is taking leadership
there may be doing it but in a very
disorderly way there's no like coherent
strategy the ones who are taking
leadership are the North Koreans they
know what they want they have an agenda
they're making progress so and I but I
agree with you on China
not wanting to destabilize North Korea
so there will have the party congress in
an info they're not going to risk
anything what they want is to maintain
stability so they were going to find a
way to you know strike a compromise all
right I get along then do you good to
see you about thanks are joining me